well let's take you back to the
Lithuanian Capital Vilnius where the
NATO Secretary General Jan stoltenberg
is speaking after a Leader's Summit
that's listening South Korea as well as
the European Union
NATO is a regional Alliance
but we Face Global challenges
what happens in Europe matters today in
the Pacific what happens in
india-pacific matters to North America
and Europe
beijing's Global assertiveness and
moscow's war against Ukraine require
even close to coordination between NATO
the EU and our indo-pacific partners
we condemn North Korea's nuclear and
missile programs including its latest
missile launch
this violates multiple U.N security
Council Solutions and pose a threat to
Regional and Global Security
NATO is reinforcing our toys with
Australia Japan New Zealand and South
Korea with tailored partnership programs
including joint work on issues like
Maritime security new technologies cyber
climate change and resilience
we will work even more closely together
standing strong for rules based in
National order
we Face the most serious security
situation in decades but allies are
rising to the challenge
NATO is more united than ever standing
strong in defense of our people and our
values
I would like to close by thanking
president aceda the Lithuanian
government and the people of illness for
hosting this historic Summit
I look forward to the Washington Summit
next year marking the 75th anniversary
of our alliance and with that I'm ready
to take some questions political
oh political
um thank you very much Elite buyer from
Politico Secretary General after reading
the communique some ukrainians have
raised concerns that perhaps some
Western capitals may be preparing for a
situation where Ukraine's NATO
membership would be a chip in a
negotiation with Russia what is your
response to ukrainians who have that
concern at the moment thank you
we had a very good meeting with
president zlensky and his delegation uh
today where he welcomed the very strong
message from NATO allies he welcomed the
establishment of the NATO Ukraine
Council and also the clear commitment to
move Ukraine closer to uh membership so
this was not an issue raised in any of
those those meetings and I think it is
extremely important to uh to recognize
that the decisions were made all NATO
allies is the strongest ever message on
Ukraine and membership that this
Alliance have ever made
by stating clearly that Ukraine will
become a member that Ukraine's future is
in NATO and also then describing the
path forward with the Practical support
for ensuring interoperability with
strength in the political ties with the
NATO Ukraine Council and then by
removing the requirement for a
membership action plan then negotiation
since
um to solve the conflict in in Ukraine
will only happen when Ukraine is ready
for negotiations and as we have stated
again and again nothing about Ukraine
without Ukraine uh what we do know is
that um is that uh the more military we
support we provide to Ukraine the more
land they are able to liberate the
stronger their hand will be at the
negotiating table
and therefore we continue uh and a
message from this Summit and from NATO
allies with new announcements of of
long-range cruise missiles of more
armored vehicles with more advanced air
defense systems and training of F-16
Pilots is that we support them to
liberate land so they will have a
stronger hand at a negotiating table
that's what this is about it's not about
NATO negotiating on behalf of Ukraine
okay we'll go to the gentleman in the
front row here
uh Ken Warrior from nikke Asia
Secretary General there was talk about
opening a NATO liaison office in Tokyo
but that was not mentioned in the
communique whatsoever uh is this uh plan
dead or is there plans to revive it
towards the end of the year is the
opening at a different location an
option and we know that France was very
much openly opposed to this plan were
there any other countries that were
opposed to the idea as well thank you
this morning I met with the Prime
Minister kishida from Japan and that was
a very good meeting where we both
recognized and
stated clearly the importance of further
strengthening the
partnership the work we do together
Japan and and NATO it is also prime
minister kashida that has so clearly
stated that what happens in Europe
matters for Asia what happens in Asia
matters for Europe and he also went to
Ukraine and and visited here and and and
and demonstrated his clear commitment to
provide support to to Ukraine we also
agreed today a new individual
partnership program between NATO and
Ukraine where we describe the different
work strands where we're going to deepen
our cooperation this is about cyber it's
about Maritime security it's about uh
country and hypertrats including this
information and in other areas where we
see the potential for NATO and and Japan
working more closely together the issue
of liaison office uh is still on the
table it will be it will be considered
in the future
John hap news agency lady in the third
row yeah
yes how will NATO engage more in the
indo-pacific security regarding China
and North Korea and how will the
partnership with indo-pacific Partners
develop in the future are you planning
to invite them next year too
strong and clear message from this
meeting and especially the meeting we
had with our partners this morning the
indo-pacific partners Australia Japan
South Korea and New Zealand is that
security is not a regional Securities
Global and therefore we really have to
stand together
China's have investments in new military
capabilities demonstrates that we expect
that China by 2035 will have 1500
nuclear warheads on missiles that can
reach North America and the whole of
Europe NATO territory we see how China
is coming closer to us this is not about
NATO becoming a global Military Alliance
but this is about
recognizing that this region faces
Global challenges and the rights of
China is is a part of that and that
China's common close doors in Africa in
in in in the Arctic but also trying to
control critical infrastructure and of
course we see them also in in cyberspace
so therefore we have
now different uh tailored programs with
all our in the Pacific Partners
describing different areas but it's very
often as it's probably about cyber
countering account and disinformation
Maritime security there is also Japanese
staff at NATO's
Maritime headquarters in in Northwood in
the United Kingdom so we are working on
different practical ways of of working
together including by participating or
participation of Asia Pacific or in the
Pacific Partners in our cyber exercises
so we are gradually expanding what we
are doing together simply because
our security is interlinked and and just
a recent missile launch of North Korea
demonstrates that because that's of
course a challenge to the region it's a
threat to to the region but it's also
undermining Global peace and stability
the the North Korean missile and nuclear
programs under and the launch we just
saw yesterday
Ard
Ro
Michael's place with a idea um Secretary
General two questions if I made the
first one also on President zolenski you
said that he welcomed the language of
the communique today that's right but he
called exactly the same communicate
yesterday absurd is he sometimes going
too far risking to alienate also
Partners who spend a lot of political
capital and real capital in order to
help him that's the first question and
the second one is where technical uh if
countries engage in security uh
agreements or guarantees for Ukraine
does that count on the two percent
spending uh goal thank you
well alongside this press conference
which NATO Secretary General Jen
stoltenberg has been speaking at we know
that the leaders Summit has wrapped up
their in Vilnius the Lithuanian Capital
at this very same time president
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
there is making some remarks alongside
U.S President Joe Biden let's listen in
and I didn't hear from all day you know
parts of the world when when Russia
began to use it I didn't hear that some
of you know countries criticized Russia
you know but I think that it was very
useful to put them so thank you so much
for this help we really counted on it
not only on this I mean that's totally
and you gave us huge support I want to
thank to all Americans who understand
that it's more than 43 billions for
today it's big support and I understand
that it's all your money but
you have to know that you spend this
money for for not not just fighting you
spend this money for our lives
and I think that we save
that the last for for Europe and for all
the walls
so thank you very much for this also
Summit
and at the end of The Summit we we had I
think this console and great success and
security guarantees as you said
that we began to speak about it in Kiev
so now we see that we had you had great
idea that's G7 and now I know that last
message that also there are countries
which join to G7 decisions and I think
it will help very much because it's real
effect that it's very competitive things
so
thank you well thank you and thank you
for acknowledging
the American people are
I think it's correct that uh
we are a large country but I think we've
given more than every Other Nation
combined
in terms of assistance and cost and the
American people are supportive
they're supportive
because they know it's it's about you
it's about more than you
despite innocent people around the world
and the the absolute brutality with
which
Putin was acting and the Russians are
moving on it's just it just sounds like
something out of the 14th century
and so but but I can't emphasize enough
and by the way I know you thanked him
but
I think we talked about it before I went
to Tokyo years more a couple years ago
the idea that kashida
is increasing their defense budget
I mean the lower their domestic budget
to Aid directly
and get directly involved in what's
happening in Ukraine
is remarkable
the sad sad news is you're in this
situation
incredible news is it's bringing the
world together
is bringing the world together in a way
that it's a hell of a price to pay
but it's bringing the world together and
people are realizing that
we just can't stand by I'll let this
kind of aggression occur
anyway I thank you and we got a lot to
talk about so
somebody's gonna have to say the Press
has to leave
are you satisfied with what you got from
NATO you were so frustrated yesterday
are you satisfied
well you've been listening there to
Ukrainian president zielinski making
remarks alongside U.S President Joe
Biden after that leader Summit has
wrapped in the Lithuanian Capital
Vilnius where nature leaders have been
meeting zelenski as you heard has been
thanking the US and the American people
for their support billions of dollars
worth of arms President Biden for his
part has been reiterating that
Washington views this as a fight on
behalf of the Free World well let's
speak to our correspondent Jonah Hull
who's following developments for us in
Vilnius Jonah President Biden has said
that what's happened at the NATO Summit
is a really strong statement of support
is that the sense there more broadly
well President Biden is clearly very
pleased with the outcome of this Summit
you heard him speaking there alongside
president zielinski talking about the
situation in Ukraine Russia's invasion
of Ukraine liking it to something out of
the 14th century he said that he's
bringing the world together in an
unprecedented way people realizing they
just can't stand by and that I think it
sums up the way he would like the
outcome of this NATO Summit to be viewed
yes NATO absolutely feels that what has
been achieved here is a powerful
statement of its support for Ukraine
that goes streets beyond what has come
before not just those 43 billion dollars
and much much more contributed by
individual NATO members on a largely
sort of as and when ad hoc basis but now
something much more concrete much more
specific
comprising a lot more certainty for
Ukraine and also a much clearer pathway
for Ukraine towards uh membership there
is the promise that it will become a
member but that is now moved on with the
dropping of the membership action plan
that can take years to complete
therefore relatively few strings
attached there is a much more
institutionalized presence for Ukraine
here at NATO with the new NATO Ukraine
Council and there is This Promise by G7
countries to create a kind of legalized
framework towards long-term security
guarantees as NATO moves towards uh
membership and that they will be very
pleased with is it everything Vladimir
zielinski hoped to get out of this
Summit uh arguably not he wanted an
invitation now he wanted a timeline
affirm timeline creating certainty as to
when Ukraine would become a member on
Tuesday he said the absence of that
would be absurd he earned a pretty rare
rebuke in one of the press conferences
here by the UK defense minister Ben
Wallace who said look a little gratitude
wouldn't go out of order he's used much
more delicate diplomatic language today
talking about an outcome that is
Meaningful that is practical and that is
important
Jonah Hall there across all of that for
us at the NATO leaders Summit in Vilnius
and Lithuania thank you Jonah well as
Jonah was just saying G7 nations are
expected to announce a plan that could
give Ukraine long-term security
assurances Russia says it's potentially
very dangerous for the West to provide
Ukraine security guarantees
um
we considered as a mistake and
potentially very dangerous because
providing any security guarantees to
Ukraine effectively ignores the
international principle of indivisible
security that said providing security
guarantees to Ukraine encroaches the
Russian Federation security this is
impossible this is fraud with very short
medium and long-term negative
consequences well we'll be getting the
Ukrainian reaction from Robert bright
there in the Ukrainian Capital cave in
just a moment but first let's speak to
Yulia chapovalova she's in Moscow Julia
Moscow has unsurprisingly sounded very
wary when it comes to Nato expansion and
these G7 security guarantees how might
it respond in practice
well actually Russia is very glad that
NATO hasn't given any specific dates for
Ukraine's entry into their lines saying
its chances for the membership as dim
it's official rhetoric here that NATO
not Ukraine is at war with Russia the
Russian authorities say that NATO is
fulfilling their goals to weaken Russia
it's a proxy warforred by the Ukrainian
proxy Army under the NATO control on the
one hand of course Ukraine obviously
hopes to receive security guarantees
from NATO to move forward and start
rebuilding the country out of their
conflicts without the security
guarantees it's impossible to do so on
the other hand
none of the NATO countries are willing
to participate in a direct clash with
Russia and risk their armies the
possibility of Ukraine's accession to
Nato was one of the pretexts for the
Russia's special miniature operation in
Ukraine Unleashed back in February 2022.
now Russia says Ukraine's membership in
their Alliance comes with obligations
will Ukraine be willing to participate
in potential conflict that NATO can
possibly get involved in in the future
Russia expresses doubts about that
Ukraine's membership seems quite
unrealistic now because it will mean
Ukraine's entry into the Western World
which means that Ukraine will be able to
determine some of NATO's agenda
something not so many NATO countries are
ready for right now therefore Russia is
not very much concerned about Ukraine's
membership this time around but uh
according to to Russia there will be a
bigger problem if Ukraine stops knocking
on NATO's closed doors all the time and
begin creating new promising military
alliances between Ukraine and a number
of certain countries which will be
interested in military cooperation or
maybe signing direct bilateral treaties
on Collective defense let me ask you a
slightly separate question there Julia
because a general who is at one point
leading operations for Russia in Ukraine
Sergey serovicin he hasn't been seen and
understand in some time he's always had
a close relationship with the Wagner
Chief you've got any pregosian do we
know where he is or how he is
yeah that's right uh wow what we hear is
that according to Chairman of the lower
house of parliament the state Duma uh
Andre Carter paulov a general surabigan
is now having some rest and is not
available at the moment some telegram
channels also say he can be in the north
Caucasus but we can't independently
independently verify those reports uh
General Sergey sura vikin his commander
of the airspace forces and Deputy ahead
of the general staff of the Russian army
and he has not appeared in public for
two weeks now since the Wagner group
armed rebellion and there is now there
is no actually decent information about
his whereabouts at the moment on June
the 29th Russian and Western media
citing their sources reported that the
general could be detained or even
arrested and on the same day while some
other channels published a comment by
Sir Vikings daughter who actually said
that nothing happened to her father and
the General's family denies at the
moment rumors of his detention or arrest
but he's he's basically appearance to
the uh Wagner Fighters he's appeal to
the Wagner Fighters uh which he recorded
at the very beginning of the pregosian
Rebellion Still Remains the last his
last appearance uh in the information of
Fielder so basically it is a mysterious
story and it is to be continued very
mysterious indeed Yulia over there
speaking to us from Moscow thank you
Julia well let's now go to the Ukrainian
capital and speak to our correspondent
there Rob McBride Rob just returning to
what we've been hearing from Vilnius
Ukraine's had security guarantees before
they've still been invaded are people
there going to feel safer after what
we're hearing today
yeah I think Ukraine and Vladimir
zielinski are putting as much of a
positive a spin as possible on this
whole Summit as dimitro calliebert of
the Ukrainian foreign minister has said
there is no substitute for Ukraine other
than full NATO membership that is their
ultimate goal but I think they will
concentrate on the positive things that
have come out of this Summit the
establishment of this NATO Ukraine
Council which does appear to be on the
road towards full membership at some
point in the future also the G7 security
guarantees that's important to Ukraine
as Vladimir zielinski has said in
various interviews that he's done also
on uh social media uh the speeding up
the fast tracking of Ukraine's
membership process when it does happen
that is to be welcomed and is also
welcoming generally all of the words of
support the uh security assurances that
have come out of this Gathering all
that's to be welcomed as well as
impractical to terms all of the
different tranches of new material of
different weapon systems and so on both
big and small we've seen bigger
commitments from France and from Germany
and then even small commitments such as
a thousand reconnaissance drones from
Norway all of this is to be welcomed
here by the Armed Forces uh as we
approach the one and a half year mark in
this conflict also the speed at which
some of these things are now being
delivered that's had been an ongoing
grievance here that it's taken an awful
lot to try to get help from bigger more
sophisticated weapon systems from NATO
countries because of the fears of of
escalating the conflict of antagonizing
Russia Etc so it's taken time to get
tanks to get missiles and longer range
missiles but now it does seem as though
the delivery of some of these more
sophisticated systems such as F-16
Fighters which have been talked about uh
for months is is at least being sped up
that it was only last month that we got
uh the uh the confirmation of F-16
fighter training for pilots and we now
hear that that training will begin as
early as next month so that at least is
providing some encouragement and maybe
leading to some anger from the Russians
as we see more drone strikes overnight
uh 15 drones being launched towards uh
towards Ukraine with most of those being
shot down and some reports of minor
damage from the couple that did get
through Robert bride there with the view
for us from the Ukrainian Capital Kiev
thank you Rob